foreign
Grace 17 podcast we're we're going to be
talking about a little bit of Babylon 5
but say hello to the lovely people Scott
while you're there hello lovely people
thanks for having me Jay I appreciate it
uh I'm happy to nerd out
any opportunity we get
um anybody that was supposed to be on
last week I know we had some technical
difficulties we were supposed to do that
this week but the gods have Smiled On Us
because JMS has been tweeting in the
evening yes and um and then so we've got
something else to talk about but I'm
just going to do the very quick intro
and then we'll crack on
[Music]
foreign
before we get into talking about the
reimagining of Babylon 5 that we've been
so looking forward to that JMS has
tweeted
um overnight all last night or whatever
it was I woke up to it anyway
um on my channel Sidetrack about October
time I did put a video out saying I was
getting told that actually Babylon fire
was probably dead
um this was running up into
um a lot of the reworking that was going
on at um at um HBO and at everywhere and
and everything was just all in a mess
was it for a couple of months but then
about six weeks ago I started hearing
actually no it's not it's not dead they
just put it on the back burner for a bit
and actually now everything's sort of
settled they're having another look and
it's still very possible likely so that
was about six weeks ago I heard that so
last night
uh Mr JMS of J Michael skinski who is
amazing with Twitter he's so he's so
giving any with
everything on Twitter he's basically
said look it's not dead yet I've had no
phone call no news is good news
don't panic
how do you how do you feel reading that
because I mean so long has gone on since
he first said we're getting the we're
getting it yeah everyone was starting to
think oh maybe not
he referred to it as Schrodinger's cat
it's alive and dead at the same time in
the Box just no one's opened the box yet
you know I I have been uh someone who
has been more positive than most because
I think that there's a lot of things
that are aligning right now to make this
happen now
um I was much more positive when Mark
pedowitz was in charge of CW because as
I'm sure you and most the folks watching
know uh pettowitz was a Babylon 5 geek
back in the 90s when he worked for
Warner Brothers JMS would slip him VHS
tapes of the series before it aired
because pettow Woods didn't want to wait
until it showed up on TV so uh but still
to this a lot of folks have been saying
well CW is making no Pilots this year no
one has actually said that Hollywood
Reporter came out and said that they
haven't bought any Pilots yet and yes
they're probably not going to buy many
if at all uh many or at all because they
are now moving towards you know more of
a focus on non-scripted television but
it doesn't mean they're not going to buy
any pilots pilots so much as JMS said
last night until he tells me it's dead
it ain't dead until he tells me it's
alive it ain't alive so we're just
waiting and singing that's like
non-scripted television and golf they're
going to be doing golf on the CW as well
yeah Saudi Arabian golf it's going to be
exciting exciting very exciting to me I
I kind of completely understand the
delay if I'm honest because not only is
Warner Brothers going through a massive
restructure which will have slowed us
down the internet it belongs to Warner
Brothers they're going to be producing
it
CW we've got first dibs on it we'll talk
about that in a sec
um but at the end of the day
um the CW have also gone through a
massive restructure they've been sold to
next star next star who have now moved
in
um there was a lot of women on about how
that deal was going to be put together
and then actually once it was decided it
seemed to go through really quite
quickly
um but again both of the companies
involved have like have had other things
on their mind I think is fair to say
yeah so
um it didn't seem to be a surprise to me
when he said it was going to get made I
was looking at the the news thinking I'm
not sure it is like I mean I mean he was
talking about having on our screens by
the end of last year which would have
been incredible well and and that got
delayed for a reason too when Mark
pettowicz was still CEO it the pilot
season they were going for was the 22 TV
season but because he knew next year I
was buying it he actually reached out to
JMS and this is now public it wasn't
public at the time and said hey we are
not gonna go with 22 because if we do
there's a good chance you don't make it
because of the transition so let's just
wait until 23. so it's already been
delayed once for that reason yeah I I
think so yeah and like I say yeah
I haven't heard that but that completely
makes sense to me and it doesn't make
sense why they said that why they
delayed it at that point because like I
said everything was up in the air plates
has been in it makes total sense
um I have heard one or two rumors
of a couple of people I speak to they're
actually Warner Brothers would love this
yeah and I'm always keeping my ears open
where I can I got I got a nice couple of
little sources through my interest in
Stargate but then MGM sacked a couple of
people so now I've got sources all over
the place
um but um
not lucky for me not so lucky for them
but it worked out in the end but um one
of the things they were actually Warner
Brothers would much prefer this to go on
HBO Max and they think it would fit
better on HBO Max
and bought the CW at the end of the day
I've got first dibs so that actually
Warner Brothers even though they make it
and they own it it's not really up to
them CW have to say no if that makes
sense and then and then they could maybe
but what do you think do you think it
would for me I think HBO Max would just
be a better fit
especially now
um I I want to see it okay so I'm not
one of those CW haters that are out
there uh I think CW has done some good
shows in the past I'm a huge fan of
Superman and Lois I think it's been a
great show uh so if it's on CW I'm good
but I do agree that I think HBO Max
especially after they go through their
little bit of transition they're dealing
with right now would probably be able to
give it more
um notoriety and also probably a bigger
budget uh but I was talking to I don't
have as many sources as you do but I was
talking to uh a source of mine
um and he had said and he's connected to
some of the uh former cast uh he had
said what he's hearing that it will
happen one way or the other
if it's going to be on TV or streaming
or even if not JMS has a way of finding
ways to get stuff out so I think no
matter what happens we're gonna know it
was in that pilot script and we're going
to see that pilot script I hope it's
actually filmed and has a cast and it
becomes a series
but regardless I'm hopeful that I at
least get to know what he had in mind
for that pilot
yeah I I
following JMS reading his tweets and
things he is so open and so honest I
think as soon as he's basically allowed
to if he gets the caught saying it's not
happening
I could see that they we would we will
find that out
um and we'll know
as soon as he knows which is also
amazing I think he's one of the most
unique creators out there at the moment
um the Terry metallis guy that runs Star
Trek at the moment he's the only other
person I know that's like it's so open
and honest with
um
I'm embargoed until Friday at three
o'clock Pacific Standard Time okay I may
or may not have seen six episodes of a
certain TV show
and Terry metallis is my favorite person
right now I bet he bloody is
very quietly thumb up
um I I'm embargo until Friday at three
o'clock Pacific Standard Time
yeah okay good but if you uh
um chill if you subscribe to us three
o'clock Pacific Standard time on Friday
so and like I said the link for your
channel is in the description so
everybody please go over and subscribe
to gray now
um if Picard season three is rubbish I
am going to never watch Star Trek again
you're gonna watch Star Trek again good
because I really really want to and they
really deserve it and the last two
seasons both maybe want to hurt myself
so um not like not like kill myself just
just like you know kicking myself in the
shin or something but um still we're
sci-fi fans that's what we do you know I
wanted to injure or in somebody else
since we were talking about HBO Max I'm
watching the uh the live chat right now
in trekgate uh said I'm baffled at HBO
through Babylon 5 m HBO Max they didn't
uh and JMS came out and said this as
well too it's all about licensing with
these folks and you have different
Warner Brothers is a very big entity
Warner Brothers TV and HBO Max are not
the same department at Warner Brothers
so HBO Max bought the license to Babylon
5 for two years and after two years that
license went away so then Warner
Brothers TV resells it and they were
just they decided they get a better deal
selling to 2B and Roku TV in the United
States I don't know about Amar
non-united States folks but
HBO Max
here so here we've got it on oh crap I
did look is it freebie is that right I
think it's on freebie yeah which is an
Amazon add-on here yeah so it's all
about licensing they like to make their
money yeah yeah
um that's that's the way I understand it
because I've had to again I've been
trying to get my head around all these
big businesses work again with the
Stargate interest in MGM and things it's
not even that they're like separate
departments it's that in some ways
they're still separate companies
absolutely the way it was explained to
me was it's a like the United States of
America how you've got 50 States now in
some ways they're individual countries
on their own but then you've got this
Federal umbrella so it's a country
but with lots of little a little
difference and that's the way kind of
this works for these big companies merge
a kind of a company
um but obviously you've got the federal
government you know so the Warner
Brothers of the federal government in
this analogy and then you got DC Puerto
Rico and the other territories that just
makes even weirder so yes
um I did a video talking about that and
obviously JMS haven't spoken at that
point because we were all confused by it
we're like well why can't they just keep
it and they could have kept it on if
they'd wanted to without very little
money but they would have made less
money from we didn't know at that point
either exactly
um but I mean I miss my point of the
timing of the two years was great
because they put it on just before JMS
basically announced that it was going to
happen so they got loads of views and
then it was just a bit worrying they
were like oh [__] we still haven't heard
and it's just come off they could have
put it back on if they wanted to
but I I argued that doesn't really mean
anything it could it could have gone
either way they could just be trying to
get either more views elsewhere or
trying to sell DVDs or trying to sell it
on Amazon you know there's lots of
reasons they could have done it if or
they just haven't decided yet the two
years is up and they just
I have plans and actually I'm not sure
they do yeah let's be honest I mean I
love Babylon five a lot of people do but
it's not a high priority for Warner
Brothers regardless if they go forward
with it or not it's never going to be a
top tier program so a lot of times it's
just not even a factor they don't think
strategically like that they're thinking
okay we have three billion dollars in
debt that Warner Brothers Discovery has
right now that we need to write off
Roku and 2B and freebie and all those
want to pay us money for our content
we'll sell our content please yeah
honestly they're at the point of selling
content or selling real estate they need
to make and no don't get me wrong
they're not in as big a trouble as
Paramount or a couple of other stream
assumes but they have massive debt they
have debt they need to sort out but
they're working towards merging all
these things together cutting costs
that it's all going to be working that
way but um
for me Babylon five and JMS as well he's
he's amazing at bringing things in at a
budget he's amazing at getting every
dollars on the screen and I think you
will again but again something I was
told that long ago is though that
Babylon 5 is one of those cult TV shows
and the reason why Warner Brothers would
actually quite like on HPR max if they
can is because it's one of those shows
that people will actually follow so even
though it hasn't got a massive
um
um you know like fan base it's not like
Star Trek is like you know known all
over the world people know Babylon fight
but they don't Maybe
but there's a cult following of us Geeks
that adore Babylon five we know that it
was you know basically copied by
Deep Space Nine and one have it
um that will go and get HBO Max just
because
on there
and Warner Brothers are well very aware
of that and they love that type of show
that you know um
people re-watch and Babylon 5 is one of
those shows that people re-watch over
and over and again and again it's for
them it's gold it's absolutely gold
um but but yeah it's um so yeah the
Warner Brothers Discovery merger halted
B5 also I don't think it helped but I
agree with you I don't think it was
actually a factor it's but it hasn't
helped
yeah I'm in I'm in the chat yeah I'm
multitasking if everybody involved was
distracted I think that's a fair way of
putting it yeah everybody involved was
distracted for 12 months and that
distraction is calming down absolutely
but you know you mentioned timing on
when HBO Max took this up and everything
too that's why we at grade 17 started
with uh my my main co-host and I Blake
have been talking about doing this show
for forever but when it became free to
watch with a subscription to most people
around the country
we saw a big influx of people interested
in the show and so and we're seeing that
so the community is growing right now
there is you know a lot of different
communities out there on social media
and everything else and is really
enjoying talking about this show again I
mean we blew up Twitter uh last year
um no offense to my friends across the
pond but we were the top trending piece
on Twitter uh the day of the Queen's
funeral I mean that's huge so uh I think
the community is growing and again
you're right it's not a Star Trek
Community it's never going to be that
big
but it's enough people to where I think
if HBO HBO Max Warner Brothers whatever
CW says hey there are people who are
interested in this who are not
subscribers right now or are not paying
for our content right now not viewing
our advertisers right now if we put the
show on the air those people come our
way and so I think that is absolutely a
factor that they're looking at and
that's another reason why I still think
CW is a potential because one of the
problems with CW currently is it was
skewed very to very to a youth audience
and they've actually said that was a
problem and that's one of the reasons
why CW is losing money part of the fix
to that is they're going to get away
from scripted television okay it doesn't
help us but the other part is getting
people who are
quote unquote middle aged to actually
watch their Network would be something
that would be a benefit to them and I
think a Sci-Fi Opera would do that so
yeah and the thing is for the CW even
Babylon 5 which compared to Star Trek
again which costs eight nine million
dollars an episode
um up to 11 12 for some
um about nine average Babylon 5 won't
cost that but compared to a reality TV
show that costs maybe a few hundred
thousand dollars an episode to create
it's Babylon 5 is still an expensive
proposition for something that they
can't they won't get the same repeat
views that you get on a stream of
service I I honestly think either way
this show will appear on both it's just
whether it goes on CW first I actually
suggested and people hated this idea but
I wasn't a big fan either but I heard it
oh you know what I'm saying that yeah
but I would say put down like an edited
because obviously on the CW it's going
to be 45 minute episodes
HBO Max you can have an hour so do HBO
Max version but put a slim down version
on CW so I put it on CW first and then
put on HBO Max I'd watch out HBO Max
it's like having um a HD version on HBO
Max but they can have a director's cut
version on HBO Max kind of thing that's
why I thought about it and don't get me
wrong it was just off top of my head I'd
rather just want HBO Max but I actually
think it'll end up on both yeah
they've done it before I mean I
mentioned Superman and Lois Superman
Lois was on CW and H and HBO Max uh at
least in the US that's how they did it
so it's they've done it before yeah I
think the arcs just didn't as well it
was on sci-fi then it was on peacock the
next day and and that's how they do it
and um
but anyway let's talk about the
reimagining let's actually talk about
what it is when you would like to happen
so
I don't I can't think of another show
that this has ever happened before where
the original creators come back and he's
getting a chance to completely reimagine
his own project I know we got the
Babylon oh sorry we got Battlestar
Galactica reboot which is probably
we'll talk about what's worked in the
past I think
Galactic is probably the um the best
example because that's the one example
that really actually worked and there's
been a couple of others but that's the
one that really worked became a cultural
icon yeah yeah
um that people actually preferred the
reboot to the original which that's
never that never happens
but but that was obviously a completely
different Creator the original Creator
you know I know it's still Glenn A
Larson was still executive producer
until he passed but I think he passed
trying to remember my baby I think
you're right I don't want to I don't
want to speak in that term but I think
you're right but part of that too is you
know rights as well it's yeah I I said
Walter Kodak died on her live once no
Walter's still with us do not do not do
that to me I need water in my life we
talked about how he was dead and then
somebody could have been thinking he
goes no he's not like he's definitely
dead we're Googling it on live on show
together Walter's not dead I don't know
where I got it from but anyway sometimes
you say things like that you really wish
um but what what do you think is like
the core this I I basically when I got
this I think Battlestar Galactica worked
because Ronald D Moore took certain core
elements of Battlestar and then he
reworked it modernized it a little bit
and went the other way and I think the
best example of that is using the Viper
so he teased us oh this is the Viper and
then this is the [__] Viper that
we're not going to use and then actually
that's what we have to use and everybody
went yay
um
Babylon 5 is going to have to do
something similar I think if it's going
to work what do you think of the core
things that he has to put in there
I mean I will start off with the with
the Babylon 5 station that's it's got to
be a Babylon fight station hasn't it
yeah he's in he's flat out said that uh
the whole reason why this isn't even
going to happen if it happens is the
name Babylon five a lot of fans have
said hey JMS why don't you do your a new
Sci-Fi show and he's flat out said no
one wants to buy that they want to buy
Babylon five and you can't have Babylon
5 without Babylon 5 in the show so it
will have a statement below whole
prequel has been the big thing isn't it
why do you do Babylon four we want to
see that I mean I saw him a couple of
days ago say because nobody wants it
yeah
Babylon 5 because that's what people
know yeah exactly but you know you
mentioned baluster Galactica I think
that one scene in the original uh
miniseries that came out in Sci-fi
channel and I grew up watching BSG the
original and I watched bowster Galactica
1980.
um so I watched the mini series when it
came out I was in college and that scene
on Galactica where they're in the museum
and you see the old Viper and they start
playing the old music that's the kind of
stuff it's like hey fans we get it we
understand which by the way Terry
metallis I can't say anything until
Friday
um but uh so for me yeah I think you
have to have the station I think the
themes are what's most important about
Babylon 5 and what I latched on to it
when I was a kid watching in 1993. is
you have a theme of
species and cultures coming of age
and learning about themselves and about
how to interact with others and you have
the theme of breaking cycles and there
may be some newbies watching one of the
gray 17s thing is we're trying to get
new people to watch Babylon 5. so I
won't go into too much details but the
idea is breaking of cycles and making
things better than what they were and
it's very hungry it's a dark show but
it's also very hopeful
so I think that's what the reboot needs
to have as well too or reimagining
yeah and I think it yeah it's got to
have those calls isn't it I think on a
very surface level if we don't see a
star Fury I'll be gutted if we don't see
anything do you think they need will he
bring back the same characters do you
think obviously different actors but um
when we bring back will we see a
Sheridan we see a delaying or we see
jakar or will he
because I mean in a way I'd be a bit sad
if they bought somebody likes your car
back particularly yeah she was so loved
and you know passed away so young really
in lots of ways
um or Garibaldi
um I think it would always be a shame
really but Garibaldi Franklin there's
we've lost so many but um
I think he's alluded to that already and
saying that he will for one the one
press release we got said that Sheridan
is Captain which was played by Bruce
Boxleitner but he even said that press
release doesn't tell you the whole story
so uh because obviously if you watch the
show in the first season Jeffrey
Sinclair played by Michael O'Hare was
the captain
um
so a lot of people were saying well
Sinclair's not in it then because you're
starting with Sheridan and he came out
and said that may not be the case and a
lot of people have said what you said
you know Andreas Katsulas
played jakar better than anyone ever
could Mira furlon played delin better
than anyone could and he said no they
were actors playing a character other
actors can play the character as well
they'll play them differently
they won't play them the same but other
actors can play those characters I think
that was him telling us that you're
gonna see some of these characters again
and but also I will say that he is very
tied to these actors as well too he
tweeted out a few months ago when
somebody was asking
um what would have happened on Babylon 5
if Michael O'Hare Jeffrey Sinclair had
stayed with the show all five seasons
and he responded and it was very telling
and I will never ask him about this
again for that reason is you're asking
it's like asking a parent what would the
color of the baby's room be if the baby
hadn't passed away
so he's very tied to these actors as
well too so I could see it going
I think some of the characters are going
to be the same for one again going back
to what we said earlier
the studios want Babylon 5. yeah so they
want John Sheridan they want delin they
want jakar and Londo
but I also think that he's going to make
sure that when he casts people for this
they're going to be people who make it
their own as well too so they're not
trying to just do what Mira did or do
what Richard Biggs did
um that they're doing their own thing
it always um sort of frustrates me a
little bit when you hear people say I
hear this with the argument with them
rebooting Firefly which
I hope they never do but um
it was like in a bottle you can never
get actors like that again does it and I
always thinking well of course you can
because in every
I almost went a bit Buffy then in every
generation there isn't that but again
um but they're a great character actors
out there all you need is somebody that
knows what he's looking for and somebody
like JMS who picks the right actors and
gets the right people and okay we might
always go oh I see you know oh we always
preferred before but
just to say that no one else can ever
play that part is I I don't agree I
think we have so many great actors in
this country in this in in you know that
that can do this it's um
well saying this so that some things are
going to be the same
he's saying this is going to be a
reimagining
um so
things are going to be different
it's fair to say would you still have a
shadow wall if you were in jms's head
right now right in this or would you go
a different way uh one I I wish I was in
jms's head because I would have a lot
more imagination than I truly do that
being said uh I think again going back
to the themes of the story I think you
do I because the the predominant theme
of Babylon 5 is again breaking that
cycle and we just uh my team just
watched the coming of Shadows which is
one of the best episodes of the show out
of season two and the whole point of
that episode is everyone is locked into
what they're doing you have the emperor
of the Centauri Emperor saying for 30
years I just did what an emperor does
jakar says no matter what I will die
today or go to prison because I'm gonna
kill the emperor Londo says I have to do
this and so forth and so on
and at the end of the show we realize
that's not the case we are not locked in
we get to make our own choices the the
main questions of Babylon 5 originally
are what do you want and who are you are
and um who are you but then we find out
the real question is where are you going
that's the question that matters we
don't learn that until later in the show
but where are you going is the real
question what is your journey and you
need the shadows for that you need the
vory launch for that maybe he'll call
them something different uh Nicole on my
show calls him the spider murder ships
whatever but you need
you need those quote unquote first ones
in the Galaxy that Define everyone's
role so you can break those roles and
for me that's what Babylon 5 is so again
uh I have nowhere near the imagination
that JMS does so if he comes and says
there's no Shadows cool man I want to
watch it I'll watch it but I think you
kind of have to
yeah I think as well this is what I mean
by there's certain things of course
certain things are iconic the Shadows is
still I actually think it would be
really difficult for him to not bring it
back and not to have the ships in a
similar way because they're kind of are
if you think about Babylon five you
think about the Shadows you think about
you know
um some of the ships some of the stuff
they keep the same some of the stuff
they'll change I liked
in a way I was kind of hoping he would
go before bye bye five Arthur it's I did
a video not long ago and it says the
best actual like most realistic fighters
in sci-fi and
um 100 yeah they actually follow physics
unlike any other ship you've ever seen
maybe the new vipers in BSG but still
yeah some of the stuff in the expanse
but um but you can follow it but but
that is just such a great vessel
um
they've got to bring these things back
but um I'll just think it's if you don't
have the shadow conflict you've got to
have something else instead and you've
still got things like breaking up the
politics back home on Earth and Earth
Force
hosting of a shame really is he couldn't
do and you're gonna have to forgive me I
can't remember the name of the damn film
and I did said this on a video and I got
it wrong
um but where we still Sheridan and
actually fighting the um the war at the
beginning in the beginning in the
beginning which I was so close
um I almost wish they could start there
because I want to see it from the
mimbari conflict and then maybe like why
they have why they built Babylon 5 and
you know like so I almost like him start
a bit sooner I know he's not going to
but I almost I would have liked to send
that more because in the beginning it
always impacted me how you know so then
Barry come up and their weapon doors are
open and this is we're showing you what
we have that was such a clever way of
setting that conflict up
um the I I'd love to see almost what he
would do with that now and I don't think
we're going to see it
um but I think it would be a shame
anyway well I I
I think he's going to take it in a
different approach too one of you know
and I met I saw somebody on the chat say
too that uh audience these days don't
have the attention span that we had in
the 90s to handle a novel on television
which is what Babylon 5 was and so as a
novel on television he was able to do
that in having you ask questions and
then answering those questions as you
went so for example the battle of the
line which is seen uh and in the
beginning as well which is Jeffrey
Sinclair in a star Fury we didn't see
the battle of the line fully until
season four or actually actually season
four because we saw Sinclair's
perspective but then in season four we
see delin's perspective and I'll
intertwines into in the beginning the
movie uh so what I'm getting at here is
he's going to take a different approach
in storytelling he's already said that
he said that people need to stop
thinking of it like it was the 90s show
stop thinking of it as 22 Episodes a
season stop thinking about it as a
five-year Arc for one he knows because
he experienced it last time no one's
going to guarantee you five years no
you're gonna guarantee you a pilot once
they buy the pilot and then maybe if
you're lucky a first season and then you
go from there but he's also said on
Twitter
that he wants to try something new
something that hasn't been done before
he hasn't said what that is I have ideas
but again I don't have his imagination
so I'm probably wrong
but so I think we need to look at this
as
something different it's going to
probably have the same tropes it's going
to have a star fury it's going to have a
John Sheridan but it's going to be
different and it's going to be a
different experience so people who are
coming to a brand new who never watched
the old show
they're going to have a new experience
and learn about these characters learn
about these stories and us who grew up
with it or came into it in the 2000s or
whatever
we're going to have a new experience too
because we're going to learn about this
universe in a different way so I agree
with you I I want to learn more about
the back story I want to know about B4
and I want to know about the minbari and
the Centauri and what happened in the
great Shadow War a thousand years ago
but I also want a good story and so if I
get a good story I I'm I'm good because
at the end of the day I can go back and
watch my remastered five seasons of B5
even the ones with Byron oh
but
um now I have a new story to watch too
it's the same reason why I'll still turn
on the old baluster Galactica
but I also have BSG and maybe I'll have
another Battlestar Galactica down the
road I mean I can watch all of those
things like this doesn't take anything
away I just it just drives me crazy
sometimes where people get so panicked
that something's going to get rebooted
it'll ruin the original
yes we won't
it'll still be there
don't worry
um but but yeah
um
I I I do think we have to get away from
this idea that like you said then that
this is going to be the 90s show just
revamped or or looking differently or
whatever
um because
he says more than once doesn't he that
you know this is no this is like if I
was going to have this idea now
with all the experience I've got as a
making out as a writer as a Creator what
would I do and it's a blank slate so
he's got this core idea which I think is
like you've you've said it beautifully
there that it's about breaking those
cycles and breaking those
um
um institutions or something in a way
you know it's just like the the status
quo isn't necessarily
the right way to go and I I felt like it
was um it was like children and parents
and trying to break away from your
parents or something it was it was it
was I remember because when I watched
this the first time around I was a young
teenager I wasn't about 16 17 and that
whole thing about get out of my Galaxy
at the end of you know the end of The
Shadow conflict that sort of hit me
because I felt like I was
that was me trying to break out into the
world something
um
and I I so if you've got that core
thought yes you don't need anything else
you can go you can go anywhere with it
and that that's got to be exciting for a
Creator to be able to do to give that
opportunity
um but we can I honestly think we could
sit here and guess what I'll say what we
would like all [__] day and because
he can actually do anything
um like you said that he might not even
go the war route he could go some other
way it'll be a massive shame because the
battle sequences were fantastic I mean
you watch them now and just like the
special effects like
one America only one American only one
human has ever stood before us and uh
and won he's behind me and you're in
front of me
but that's another reason why though I'd
love him to get this on HBO Max because
I do think streaming services people are
only just suddenly starting to realize
what you can do in a streaming service
and one of the things is you don't have
to sit to the old rules it doesn't have
to be 22 Episodes it doesn't have to be
aired every week it doesn't you don't
have to even air them every year
um I mean look what they do on Netflix
with a couple of their big shows at the
moment
the show explodes the actors get busy so
they just have a two-year Gap and
they're not bothered they'll it'll be
back when it's back don't worry
um but also I remember watching
something about Battlestar Galactica
um the reboot they were planning uh with
them Ismail and he said well one of the
things we want to do is we're going to
drop three episodes in one day because
there's a battle sequence and it's a
three-way battle sequence so we're gonna
see each of the perspectives
we can do that in a stream of service we
can't do that on anywhere else so in a
way I think somebody creative like
jmsley saying like you know I want to do
something new I'm like put him on a
stream of service give him a bit of a
budget put him on a stream of service
and let him do whatever he wants and I
should see what he thinks
agree because you know my first well my
first interaction with JMS a lot I mean
he also did Masters of the Universe
Shira and Real Ghostbusters all three of
them in my Pantheon of 80s geeked but my
first real interaction with JMS that I
knew of was Captain power and the
soldiers of the future and hear me out
so Captain power they sold toys that
were the captain Power Jets and you
actually shot at your TV and there were
little reticles on your TV and if you
hit them you score points and if you
didn't hit them they ejected your
captain power out of your toy so you
interacted with the show
what I'm getting at here is JMS has
always been about trying new things so I
would love to see him get a chance to do
something different and find new ways to
explore the medium
and push the boundaries which is what
he's always done that's why we had
serialized Babylon 5 in the 1990s when
sci-fi shows weren't serialized DS9
would become serialized
but not yet even even
five in a lot of ways well that's a
debate for another day and I'm happy to
have that debate don't get me wrong I
don't think an intense story but I think
they saw Babylon five and okay we're
maybe inspired because you know there
are a lot of similarities between the
shows you know in the very same way that
um uh JMS was inspired by bester the uh
with the telepaths not the best her
character but best or the author and so
forth and so on but that's a debate for
another day which I'm happy to have fair
enough
um
but you know there's like I I I've
always thought Babylon five was ahead of
its time and somebody said that you
can't have it now because people don't
have the extent of the um the attention
span
I don't agree
um I think we're more used to it now
than we were when Babylon 5 came out
um I think you're watching something
like Game of Thrones
um I was thinking that like say I watch
Game of Thrones a second time and I'm
there I'm not gonna go I'm gonna take a
notepad with this and I'm gonna write
people's [__] names down because that
person probably won't appear for six
months now and I'm gonna have to try to
remember who it is and um you know you
almost like wanna you wanna like make
notes when you're watching the damn show
and then
I I think people are better at that now
because we're more used to it and that
show
if ever you want to show that a lot of
American television where you've got the
last time on and they do that but
they'll do that after a break on reality
shows don't they go remember what
happened three minutes ago yes I
remember three minutes ago
um they never did that on Game of
Thrones and I [__] wish they would
because I'd like to say okay right I
know this character I vaguely remember
his Facebook I can't remember who he is
so I mean yeah a Babylon five those were
so far ahead of its time that had that
overrun story like that like say Star
Trek next Generation didn't DS9 did
Voyage you did and all of the streaming
shows do that now
um and you know it was actually a weird
thing when strange new worlds didn't you
did something else they were being retro
with their episodic television
which is just like no that just do what
we want you know yeah spaceship go
explore do stuff strange new worlds is
my favorite new track although
[Music]
that may change next week on Friday
maybe
[Laughter]
Generations um what can you tell me
Friday yeah we'll be installed until
Tuesday I'm sorry
um well yeah no no it's I I just I just
think it's it's it is such an exciting
idea I hope it doesn't get lost
in the
um in all the changes that are going on
at the moment I'm hoping it it it it
does get a chance because I say if you
give him even a reasonable budget I
think he could do something really
amazing so if it does come back
is there anything that you would say
hands up right now
you'd be most excited about or that
there's is there one thing from the show
you just think he's got to do that okay
well I would say most excited just in a
meta aspect is I have three kids and
being able to sit down with my kids and
watch new Babylon five that's what I'm
most excited about because my kids have
watched me watch the shows and Dad
that's
that's old 90s stuff what are you doing
but if I could sit down and have them
watch something new and get them to be a
gateway drug into the old stuff that's
what I'd be most excited about but to
answer the other part of your question
what does he need to do I I think it
needs to be a story of hope I am so
tired of sci-fi and mainstream
quote-unquote horror like I'm thinking
Game of Thrones and I'm thinking
um uh um a Walking Dead and shows like
that where there literally is no hope
all your friends and family on these
shows are gonna die it's just a matter
of when and even if they don't die their
lives are so meaningless now that
there's no I I joked about I didn't joke
I talked about this in one of our
episodes recently where it's not just
important to survive you have to have a
reason to survive and that's where
Babylon 5 and Star Trek do a really good
job usually and that is yes we're gonna
go through some dark times some of us
aren't going to make it some of us are
going to make really bad decisions
looking at you Londo but at the end of
the day
we are going to come out of this better
than where we started as a species
I need that and I I think that's a given
I think that's something that GMS would
absolutely do but I need hope in my
sci-fi
yeah I I agree and I I even Star Trek
has was was always the positive sci-fi
it was always the world is better life
is better even that the new new Trek
stuff like discovery
we go into the future we're all really
excited there's the burn everyone's life
is awful what
is it like
but I I agree with it in B5 there that's
even though it's looked like we were
the the the universe could we could all
get we could all lose if we came out
when we got in everything was but but
also I mean we did it together and that
was an important message in the 90s I
think it's even more important now I am
going to use the dreaded woke word from
which I detest but what I use it you
know what I mean
is
this show going to have people angrily
shouting woke at it when it gets made
yeah and those people are dumb I'm sorry
uh I'm I'm not going to sugarcoat it uh
if you I've had people on social media
say oh B5 better not be the reboot
better not be woke I'm like do you
realize that originally in the Gathering
Dylan was meant to be a male and that
she was going to transition transition
to a female now they couldn't pull it
off because of several reasons uh
dealing with Mira furlon's voice and the
makeup and everything else I feel so
much in the network went ballistic I
don't actually there was no because uh
in the original plan which the JMS has
released and we are going to do a show I
did see it but I always wondered if the
exactly I can't I'll just imagine the
executive somewhere going I'm not well
let's use another example
um Ivanova and Talia in the 90s yeah
yeah very difficult The Babylon 5 was
always quote unquote woke and if you
didn't pay attention to that I can't
help you uh Progressive sci-fi is
Progressive sci-fi and it makes us
uncomfortable that's the point of
Science Fiction going back all the way
to the 1800s and sci-fi novels the point
was to look at our culture today
and make us feel uncomfortable and make
us think about what is actually
happening here so it's going to be that
and if if you get uncomfortable to a
point where you actually you don't and
you just can't handle it
that says more about you
than the medium and that's for any
medium so I I'm probably going to get
some people you know wigging wagging
their finger at me but that's fine uh at
the end of the day that's what sci-fi is
I mean it's best yes I mean it's the
same thing too like Star Trek today is
too woke in the original series you had
one guy who had black on one face and
white on the other and black on one face
and white on the other and they didn't
like each other uh excuse me
I looked up William Shatner came out to
me recently and said something about it
being um Star Trek was never political
and then there's a picture of him stood
next to that and have you forgotten
nostalgic
I will not say anything mean about a
90-something-year-old man but yeah I've
met him twice I love the fella um I've
even read his books and I didn't hate
them um yeah and
I loved most things he's done I've just
finished watching Boston Legal for about
the ninth time yeah
um but he is in his 90s and and that was
a stupid thing to say
um
for me the best sci-fi is brilliant
because it can use metaphors to say
things you can't say yes in other things
and also if it makes you go oh
and and pokes you a little bit and pokes
your what you think is right or wrong
whatever and you know then that's it's
doing its job that's what it's for you
know supposed to make you think if you
don't want to do that uh there's plenty
of reruns of Duck Dynasty for you yeah
exactly yeah and actually the things
that maybe JMS will poke might be a
little bit different today because
things are different you know it's like
gay rights May okay well gay rights has
changed into transgender and all these
things racism and everything else yeah
um so I I obviously think actually that
for us as much as different actually
things haven't really changed yeah a
great deal
um and he'll deal with it the same way
but unfortunately before
people joined and before sorry before
people see this show they will shout
woke it and they will say it's crap
and that's what frustrates me people
shouting the Quantum Leap was going to
be a load of rubbish and load everything
and actually Fair it's an okay show it's
not the greatest show in the world it's
okay that's it's pretty good but it's
not work
it's just got a Chinese fella in the
system that's all Chinese but you know
what I mean yeah evidence
just throwing out there
um but I actually that's a whole other
thing too is
there's a lot of SQL reboots going on
right now and I think Quantum Leap is a
good example that Ghostbusters afterlife
which is uh I love uh I have all my
Ghostbusters here you can't see
um but so there's there's other ways you
can do it too I don't think Babylon 5 is
going to do that but it's interesting
no I think these this idea this modern
thing of doing sort of continuations
soft reboots it's all the TNG was it's
not new
um and and people hated TNG when it came
out people going nuts this isn't Star
Trek and now you know it's that that's a
lot of people that's their Star Trek but
um I I'm a big Stargate fan this this
channel we talk about Stargate more than
we talk about anything else and we're
we're just as gate as Stargate fans
we're just desperately hoping for a
continuation
um and not a hard reboot hard reboot
when you've got 17 seasons of a show is
you know nearly 20 years it was on
screen it's hard but Babylon 5 for me is
one of those that it's almost ideal
because it was only on for five years we
won't include Crusade and whatever but
um well you don't want to include
Legends of the Rangers come on I don't
you know what I don't even think I ever
saw it it was only on Sci-fi channel one
time Super Bowl weekend is when they
released it so I'm not even sure go over
here to be honest but um but a lot of um
well look the head of Warner Brothers
and saslav was recently talking about
what show is going to be in HBO Max and
he basically came out straight up and
said it's got to have a franchise
potential and that was like if it
doesn't franchise potential
putting James Gunn in charge of that and
saying go because he knows it's got an
IP
we could talk about that in a second but
um but but yeah I say what I'm trying to
say is that Babylon 5 is a show that has
that potential it has a Lock Stock fan
base immediately and actually it's like
a fresh Sci-Fi show in lots of ways
because it's over is it 30 years old
when was it 95 yeah the actual the the
30th anniversary is next month this
month February 22nd is when the
Gathering aired exactly 30 years old
it's it's primed for a hard reboot and
it could kick-start something if JMS
does it right which I think he will
there could be a big franchise it's a
big universe
he could do anything else with it
while as you mentioned DC and James Gunn
I'm a Marvel guy I'm just throwing it
out there I'm a Marvel guy as well
um I I Batman's my favorite superhero
but Marvel of just a way better job over
the last 10 years but as we've never had
you on the channel before though and
we've I think we've covered Babylon 5
nicely we've got we've got five or ten
minutes left cool
um so what do you think about what he
threw out last week what James Gunn took
down out
um it was not as exciting as I was
hoping for I have not been a fan of the
quote unquote Snyder Universe much
um for one I don't think anyone has
understood Superman on film since
you know the Reeve movies
um Superman Returns kinda figured it out
kinda
but I was not a fan of Man of Steel
don't get me wrong Henry Cavill I'm fine
with he's a good actor I really want him
to be Commander Shepard in Mass Effect
but that's a whole other story
um
but I was not a fan of Man of Steel or
any of those I think the best one to
come out of him was the original Wonder
Woman uh but even they kind of screwed
the pooch on that one with the sequel so
I'm I was all for oh God I know I know
but the first one was great and I have
two daughters and it was great to watch
Wonder Woman with them and have a good
movie but um
they really I was I was hoping for more
I was hoping for a more distinct plan
and
it was kind of uh on like okay we're
getting another Swamp Thing okay yeah
um
it's all going to depend on Superman
isn't it I mean the Brave and the Bold
uh the bad family thing okay whatever I
I haven't really read Batman comics
since like Nightfall in the 90s so but
they need to be able to pull off
Superman
and the whole idea of Superman is for me
and for I think many fans is
he is going back to that story of Hope
and sci-fi he is what we try to be he is
what we try to strive to be and so I
don't need emo Superman
I don't need a legal alien Superman
I need Superman who grew up in Kansas
who is a Boy Scout who believes in apple
pie and what we could be as a uh I need
Captain America with a cape is what I
need I think
yeah I think the best Superman movie to
come out in the past 20 years was
Captain America the First Avenger yeah
that was fantastic I I don't think we're
Superman it's somebody that's got all of
that power and actually doesn't want to
use it sort of thing and that's the
that's the the Paradigm with Superman is
that he could do he could be and they
try to do this in um Batman vs Superman
and actually I think they did a quite a
good job other than the why would you
say that name
um I actually quite like Batman vs
Superman because Batman was scared of
Superman because he said he could do
anything
and he didn't trust even if it's a one
percent chance something and I always
liked that that idea with Superman that
he can do anything but he doesn't he you
know he wants to be a force of good
because most people look at that and
going if I could do anything I so would
it's like you know and then I'd be evil
um so yeah I think I'd agree with that I
I just look at what he's put out and I
just think
any story can be done brilliantly if
it's done well right when they're making
Ant-Man like so we're both Marvel guys
when they were doing Ant-Man I was
watching that going and that ain't gonna
work right and it what they knew it was
a bit stupid so they did you know a
little bit of tongue-in-cheek in the
right places
when they said can we change the name I
have a bit of a joke no we can't you
know but they did it right and it worked
so I'm looking at like Bray from the
balls and I'm thinking that's a stupid
idea and Batman and Robin and I remember
the comic
and I was actually really pleased with
myself that I remembered it correctly
exactly I did this live video when I
read what he'd done and I just talked
about it and from memory and I actually
vaguely remembered the comic that um
it's actually Batman's son Robin's
Batman's son in this one Damien yeah I'm
so proud of myself
um I geeked on that but um
every time we've had Robin in the movies
before it's not worked it doesn't even
work that well in the animated stuff and
the animated stuff's way better than a
lot of the anime you know the live
action we've seen
um so that makes me very nervous and
obviously they've also got potential of
Batgirl which never works and we've got
all these other things
the Superman storyline
just sounds like a hard reboot again and
I was like [__] sake do we really need
to see an origin story of Superman again
do we no I don't think you don't have to
I think what you do is you do kind of
what Marvel did with Spider-Man and say
we already know about Uncle Ben okay we
know that yeah
we'll mention him so I mean
um going back to JMS
what I would like to see is some of what
his run was and with his Superman run
some of it was a little uh okay he's
grounded and he walks Across America not
so much but there's one uh scene in the
uh the JMS Superman comics and I'm
blanking on which one it was where
Superman is talking to a woman who's
about to jump from a building
and he basically has a conversation with
her and he says I could stop you
but I'm not going to
I'm going to say I'm going to say here
and I'm going to stay with you all night
and you make the choice because if I
stop you you're just going to make the
same Choice again when I'm not here and
it was a
it's it's Superman grasping with the
idea that he is a god he has the ability
to do whatever he wants if he wants to
pluck that girl off the roof and bring
her down that's fine but that's not
going to help her
and he has to grasp with that that's the
kind of stories that you could do with
Superman that would make sense you don't
have to blow up Metropolis you don't
have to have Zod in the first movie
you don't have to have him
the capital of the United States blowing
up and instead of Superman trying to
save people he walks out with his head
down and flies away because he got he
got beat
that's not Superman and so what I'm
getting at here is you don't need an
origin story you need to examine
the person and I think gum could pull
that off I just think after that I mean
there's not much for me to bite into yet
of course again
I didn't know even though I was a comic
fan I didn't really know about the the
Guardians especially the new Guardians
with you know from the 2000s so when
they said uh the next movie is going to
be Guardians of the Galaxy I'm like oh
that's that's a that's a stretch and it
became Our Generation Star Wars so if
anyone could pull this off it's gun I
just
I gotta see it first
yeah my only risk is that like James
Gunn did Guardians of the Galaxy and
then he did uh Suicide Squad
which is genuinely one of the worst
movies I've ever seen really you didn't
like the suicides The Suicide Squad the
second one I thought that was one of the
most fun DC movies they put out it was a
full Bomb b movie but that was the point
they did it really straight though and
it was then you had Peacemaker TV show
which was good too but The Peacemaker TV
show I adored it's the same aesthetic it
was um it was the same yeah but I don't
know
okay it was awful and the thing is like
I'm a massive fan of Nathan Fillion so a
Nathan Fillion in a movie I was like
yeah and I was even watching this is
stupid I just that was the thing I think
maybe I went into it with the wrong
mindset I didn't even particularly like
the first Suicide Squad that one was
trash yeah but um I I genuinely I didn't
get it it missed for me and sometimes
films do then you just don't quite get
it and obviously the giant starfish
comes up at the end and I'm just like oh
for [__] sake
um
I I just say and you know what I don't
even think I watched it all the way
through I think I might have turned it
off I hated it that much so I don't even
think I watched it to the end
but then when Suicide Squad sorry when
Peacemaker came out I don't like
thinking I saw a couple of adverts and
but you know what got me though I saw a
clip of the starting of the of the dance
yeah the the intro that's yeah I say
okay that looks like a show for me yeah
but again watching John Cena do his
little thing yeah and the T-1000 yep oh
it's amazing and
um for me that was that that was one of
the best shows of that year I absolutely
adored it and and I'm ashamed it is
genuinely shame they're pushing back a
second season because I would have loved
it and I didn't know if I'm going to get
a second season you're gonna get Waller
which is gonna basically be the second
season but yeah
he suggested I didn't hear you yeah I
will I will be the first to say that I
grew up a Marvel Fanboy and part of that
is I think Marvel superheroes are more
grounded and I like that I like that
they're in New York I like that they're
not usually Gods
um so I've never been really a DC guy
except for Superman because well I'm a
you know a kid from the 80s so I grew up
with watching Superman on Beltone right
now so there you go there you go so I'm
taking my belt up so I can show people
that stand up and show my crotch it's
very same like you're stripping for us
already it's all it's only one o'clock
my time
um seven o'clock here it's nothing else
okay so it's time yeah it's time to lose
the belt uh so I'm all again as we were
talking about B5 I just want a good
story so if you give me a good story
I'll be happy nice I've been wearing it
for like 20 years I'm on my my fifth
belt
the booklet I still say and this is
going to be one of those where you know
Bob and the chat's gonna hate me more
but the best Batman film of all time is
still mask of the Phantasm
that's great I just said to you the the
animated stuff was better than that
Kevin Connolly is my Batman
even
um uh the Batman's comment was called
Batman samurai or something that was
done a couple of years ago I really like
that they sort of did a
different take on it I I saw the
animated stuff was always better
um the first Batman movie was great they
were Michael Keaton I I thought that was
brilliant yeah
that one was 89 Batman was was great
because it was something different it
was but everyone's been trying to ape 89
Batman in one shaper form since then and
again I don't need a hunky-dory Batman I
don't need Adam West
but can we can we not do the whole
brooding thing anymore for a while again
and that's why I love the Animated
Series yeah Batman was a dark character
but he wasn't like
he wasn't just dark for the sense of
being dark and unfortunately it's what
we've had for the most part since then
yeah it's more like a almost like a
Punisher we need more isn't it where
he's he's from the the Marvel TV series
again that he's
Batman was always punishing people that
was his sort of thing he was angry and
that's the point
um and violent and even Robert
Patterson's I enjoyed the Robert
Patterson the Batman I enjoyed it on the
whole I liked how they did a Batmobile
that was like a bit more realistic yeah
but he was again Broody too Broody
I was not a huge fan of the new Batman
until the last act and I think it's been
out long enough where I'm not going to
spoil anything he realizes at the end
this isn't working
me just being a scary character who
beats the crap out of people
is just making things worse I need to
give people hope
and that scene of the movie
and so I'm interested in the Batman 2
because hopefully they explore that and
they explore the idea that yes he can
scare the crap out of criminals that's
what he does
but he also has to be a symbol for other
people to Aspire to
so I was like watching most of the
Batman going oh God we're doing this
again we're doing this again at the very
end I'm like oh that was the point they
were trying to tell us something
different they probably could have cut
about 20 minutes but they were telling
us something different
mm-hmm I always think all I would do for
me was I would whoever edited the first
one I would throw him out of a window
nobody else in and just go just make it
a bit snappier yes but there's not even
three hours not every not every movie
has to be epic folks no just just a
little snack a little quicker you know
the bit when he walks in and he sort of
looks around for what feels like 20
minutes
two seconds do that it goes into a crime
scene he doesn't have to look at
everything
it could just look at the dead body and
then say something he doesn't that that
scene doesn't have to be 20 minutes
either but I will say the one other
thing that the Batman I think got right
again agree with you editing was
something that had to be worked on yeah
that's the style he wanted just just
speed up a little bit knock 20 minutes
off would have felt a whole different
movie no one gets the idea that Batman's
supposed to be a detective and so the
whole idea here is he's supposed to be a
smart guy they kind of hinted on that
with the Batman they haven't really done
that much I mean okay in Dark Knight he
looks at a bullet for a bit and figures
stuff out but really
no one's really gotten the hole he's a
detective in a long time so I'd like to
see the distance Adam West really yeah
that's true
again and so in the animated yeah mass
of the Phantom does it well but that's a
whole other story
yeah exactly
Scott I'm I'm gonna
say thank you so so much I always try to
keep these things around an hour
um because um my throat hurts and
there's a there's a running joke here
that as well by the time I get to a live
video generally I need to go for a week
and um and that's just the way these
things go
um in the commentary today I'm just
going to just thank very quickly I've
seen
um our Shelley as always been amazing as
she's been gifting people
um memberships to the channel I've told
her she's not allowed to do super chats
anymore because she runs our Facebook
group Scott and she's amazing and she
does loads of help so instead she's got
around my little I see that she's been
giving out free samples left and right
she's like
she wants to help the channel and I
appreciate it but thank you so so much
Jenny thank you everybody that's got
your memberships today
no just don't cancel them keep them so
and that helps
thank you very much but um but no that's
really good and like I say I'm sorry I
couldn't speak to you guys in the
comments because I can't think and talk
and read you can Scott I can't but um
thank you so so much yeah I can't do
that either I just end up hit myself in
the head don't do Marine candy idiot
oh man that's gonna hurt
um Scott I would 100 love to come get to
get you back and just geek out on
something else maybe in a week or two
when we can talk about Star Trek that
would be interesting I'm happy too I'm
happy to I I love being a nerd I see
also Mega's in the chat as well too I
need to get mega to talk more as well so
yeah but no I'm happy to join whenever
uh whenever we get a chance to chat I
love it excellent we will yeah people in
your chat so that's great yeah oh and
now we've got a really really nice
Community growing over here now that um
people that they're always on they're
always got an opinion
um
I then have to explain to them why
they're wrong and give them a correct
opinion but you know that's they love it
everyone loves being talked down to no
we don't do that everyone's opinion is
valid and it's no I'm going to change
that most people civilians are valid
some people's opinions gets them blocked
but that's a that's a completely
different valid opinion I just will
block you that's fine I'm just like I'm
not now YouTube will definitely delete
my channel from that so no bye-bye um
some people just not very often but you
know you get the odd one but um no thank
you so so much hopefully we might hear
something Babylon 5 related very very
soon let's let's fingers crossed that we
do
um I have a horrible feeling just just
before we go then one one last thing
Babylon 5 related how confident are you
if we had to say give it a percentage
that we will get an announcement
this year
a positive or negative announcement 100
right 100 uh because at the end of the
day one of two things are going to
happen they are going to green light the
pilot and that will happen here in the
next several weeks because they have to
go to Pilot and that's going to have to
happen in the springtime or they will
call JMS and say it's not happening yeah
now
um so 100 we'll know with the CW this
year now will we know what happens with
the script that he wrote might give it
about 75 because I think there's always
a chance something else happens
and how confident are you that it's
going to get made
as a TV media Tech result
as a TV media I would say I think 75 I
think it's going to happen now will it
get made as either TV or a comic or uh I
mean like that 100 I think JMS has an
idea and he'll get it out there it's
just a question of how and I've talked
to some of the original cast members and
they've said the same thing they've said
no matter what JMS is a dog with a bone
he will get it out there one way or the
other yeah I I said on it being TV and
like you said I think the next two two
months if we haven't this is a bit
similar to I keep telling people about
star Stargate really if April we need to
have known by April
um well it should be filming by April
really yeah they're gonna hit the uh the
airwaves in August September time it has
to be yeah well we won't necessarily
well no if they go to HBO Max that that
whole thing goes out yeah but um but
yeah if it's CW it has to be yeah the
next thing
um and they have to film The
green yeah they'd have to Green Light It
by and be filming by April
um or at least we'd have to know what
the schedule was by then
um or or I don't think yeah it won't
happen and we'll just hear from JMS and
it's not going to happen but like I said
I agree with you I think he'll just get
out another way but I'm I'm 50 50 on
whether we're going to get this on
television I just hope that
the Warner Brothers can grapple it away
from the CW
so I can get a better product I will I
will put a plug-in for JMS if you want
to be the first to know join his patreon
because he has said over and over again
as soon as he gets the call one way or
the other he's posting the patreon so
I'm a patron of JMS and I think it's
well worth it excellent yeah yep I think
so yeah
um I'm not but I I might have to because
I just need the news ASAP
this is one of those shows that like I
said
we would go looking for you know and
that we would genuinely be there's not
many shows you go you know something
gets announcing like oh that's great
that'd be interesting this this will be
one of those like Pub let's have a beer
I'm very very happy about this and
that's it
it was like 10 years ago where I think
it was Verizon had a streaming service
but it was only like 15 minute clips and
for some reason they had the license to
be five so I was watching B5 in 15
minute Clips that's how sick I am and I
own the DVDs I don't understand
we're mental we're mental for these
shows my momentum
but yeah and let's just open just
something amazing which I'm but I'm sure
he will but again thank you so so much
Scott um everybody like say the link um
if you're not
um if you don't know gray 17 the link is
in the description please go and find it
um I'm also a subscriber so it's on my
subscriber list as well if you can't
find it there you can go there and find
it but if you just search grade 17 it'll
come up this gray 17 podcast isn't it
yes sir okay let's go we will hopefully
see you again sir
thank you I would love to have a lovely
day go get yourself some lunch because
it's lunch time there I'm gonna go get
my tea and then and I've got to put my
belt back on because it's
priorities yes
so thank you so so much and we'll see
you next time
say bye Scott
adios see you later
[Music]